um title of my talk as you I assume are
still literate its phrasing
communicating data science through gifts
tweets and classic misdirection if you
haven't seen Archer you can take a nap
or whatever yeah so my name is marek I
am the tidy versed dev advocate at our
studio not a real data scientist and I
my job description is you know gruff but
lovable driver mechanic and an
occasional muscle yeah so if you know me
at all it's probably because I go on
Twitter I would say tweeting is now
maybe only like 90% of what I do but
down since I first made these slides so
yeah this wasn't the only option for
titles for this talk is that a reference
I should get are you all just saying
random words and the reasoning behind
this is because it's like kind of how I
feel operating in life in general and
certainly in the data science realm and
in fact I like to say that I am a data
scientist which means a superficial
pretender to knowledge luckily in
college I majored in science and society
which means I know everything about both
of those things now it's called science
and technology study so if nothing more
I'm actually a very well trained sayest
ya the origin story basketball
so I actually first started using are
like 2001-2002 for fantasy basketball
because I was really cool in high school
yes so I was really into fantasy
basketball and being like sixteen or
whatever I randomly found like an
open-source programming language so I
could win my league fast forward to a
few years back and they banned our in
that league luckily I can do some pipe I
please it's not what's keeping me back
the bat pig yeah if you can see here
I've got this sticker of my dog the bat
pig yes so I was gonna like immobilizer
for like two years
gotten a skateboarding accident and my
dog got like Twitter famous like ten
years ago he's really big in Japan and
so while I was in a leg immobilizer
managing my dog's social media account I
started to you know learn a little bit
of programming here and there dive into
who knows what and I used this thing
called buffer so that looking at
pictures of cute dogs didn't just take
over my life to schedule my posts I they
don't have like an affiliate program but
if they did I should be getting cash
yeah and also because again the Japanese
time zone things so that was kind of how
I like learned learned the Twitter as my
mom calls it but when it comes to our
it's more kind of just like me you
learning out loud like oMG I just
learned a thing and that's okay
I so it's funny to me that my Twitter
feed is useful to other people because
really it was just a way of me keeping
track of the things that I was reading
and learning and then making sure that I
didn't try to read all the things so I'd
be like oh if I just read I won't post
anything I haven't read so if I just do
five a day that seems like a healthy
limit sometimes I go over
yeah so that was kind of what started my
tweeting deal 100% selfish remains true
but it turns out that I I guess this was
useful to other people
patently thought it was and this is like
pre bow tie photo so pretty Oh G right
there yeah I was taken aback also really
he followed this up by saying hope so he
didn't have to keep retweeting me so
it's laziness on his part yeah and I
know real data scientists are in the
room so we've got some empirical
evidence that yeah I am in fact the key
to a successful blog post for Edwin
Fallon yeah so uh my inference there
actually an overlap between things that
are selfish and things that are useful
to other people thank God hello Anushka
Sharma yes we can be LinkedIn friends
I'm gonna accept that later don't take
it personally
yeah and you might have noticed that
slight non-technical burns and Hadley
then like followed up with this but then
before I gave my first talk he's like Oh
like you know just let people know you
don't have to be the greatest scientist
to contribute so we kind of back pedaled
this one but ya know Lucy who could not
be here today I think put it best you
know she was saying like okay the way I
read this is that if you're non tech
she's a fire go to two dancing girls
trophy emoji and like my line here was
like Abby that fire two dancing girls
trophy emoji you want to see in the
world but then somebody replied to that
with saying be the two girls one cup you
want to see in the world and totally
ruined it so farewell to this slide yeah
but so I'm really into words a yeah so
there there is a word for that it's
called exoteric yes james long keeping
it yeah thanks linkedin yes so uh i am a
bit of an EXO terrorist or yeah that's
my jam why because a lot of times i'm
reading things and they are half in
English and half in squiggly i actually
made that first when i opened at apology
book and somebody replied back being
like they're called contour lines
that's typography
don't post apology jokes on immature
lesson learned
yeah um so yeah you might think that
this is me engaging in it bit of aporia
it's not I am still surprised by the
fact that people find what I do useful
hypotheses whoo oh how are we not
already connected yeah so um my efforts
are not always tidy in fact a lot of
times it's you know but like Jenny Bryan
calls it data rectangle Aang for me it's
like idea rectangle I'm so yeah I I have
a lot of untidy efforts I'll be a tidy
handwriting do not use that syntax
anymore
but yeah so like my working the
hypothesis here is like I think people
kind of like seeing that thoughts don't
always fit in data frames like a
literally please do not submit all of
your pull request like this but like
sometimes words are not that useful and
I have to like draw on things and put
emoji there and maybe people jam with
that I also post a lot of other people's
content so that's like hypothesis number
two that people like seeing that maybe
but and here's where there's like a real
newcomer pitch it's not necessarily new
novelty is a little overrated
Hilary Parker's like guide to package
writing remains fire emoji and so it's a
lot of content that like you wouldn't be
reading it if you already knew how to do
it and I guarantee you that if you're
learning how to do something somebody
else is also probably learning how to do
it so you know give it a shout or not
that's like my last hypothesis yeah so
outcomes where did this get me well I
got to partner with Elijah Meeks making
a visualization of the entire core
Archer which we did code by hand and
Elijah is actually the head of data
visualization at Netflix and also
valuable if not unbearably so I ended up
analyzing it using tidy text so like
real data scientists or whatever like D
Robb and Julia who write books or like
oh can you review this and I did I also
got involved with our open side which is
an awesome organization I they invited
me to their uncommon I did like a video
chat and I the first thing I said I was
like I don't know C++ and it turned out
that was ok and they also have this
awesome package review process I was
really worried that like all I was gonna
have to say I was like yes this is a
package it turned out it was so I did
say that but it also turns out that like
they knew I wasn't gonna you know make
it more performant or who knows you know
like experts actually need newcomers so
my feedback was like oh all of this
warning coming up every 5 seconds is
really scary two hypothetical newcomer
so uh let's get into tradecraft this is
the anatomy of a tweet that's not me uh
yeah like cool tutorial using package
name title author handle relevant hash
tag it's like kind of how I roll
and again because I'm selfish I take a
lot of pictures screenshots whatever so
this is like a tweet where I'm talking
about something and here's what I think
people actually see it's like oh like I
need that cluster II bubble thing and
that's why they look at it and it's
useful to them yeah and unsubstantiated
hypothesis
I hear attribution I treat my future
self like I will have a traumatic brain
injury at any given time this is
reflected in my code comments and
throughout my life including like my
code comments to self on post-its yeah
so I put attribution on everything I
think people like that and the tweet
itself is not the content
so Jenny Brian makes awesome
presentations that are breat unto
themselves and then I put them together
and like ruin them into collages so that
I can find what I need again and this is
how a lot of other people I guess yeah
like people like to read pretty
minimally so if you can break it down to
like hieroglyphs they're into it yeah so
like my tweet ours reader run i maybe
some people tweet things they don't read
that would make me incredibly nervous I
also never didn't like always with the
reading for class and so maybe that's
not totally or whatever relatable my
retrievable that's what the pictures are
for again selfishly so I can find
whatever it is I was just reading again
it's a lot easier to find like a picture
of a giant paperclip than it is to find
a word relevant again kind of matte and
real you do you two dancing girls
explosion tada if tweeting is not your
thing don't do it I what I do is not for
everyone I have a pretty big fan club
over in stack overflow our chat and
elsewhere the our finance conferences
they may be renaming at them are a box
and club likely Hadley Wickham fan club
but anyway so yeah like do your own
thing and the my favorite feature of
Twitter is mute own it and use it
liberally so is this all just classic
misdirection kinda I guess in a weird
way this
is me contributing to open source and
now I've contributed in some other ways
too but you know what if this helps
other people learn things and they don't
have to ask like Hadley or Jim Hester
Gabor max about it then and they can
like build out a sweet package well I'm
telling somebody where a tutorial is
then I consider that a contribution in
its own right because I want whatever
sweet featured they're writing and then
I have this whole analogy about a
Portuguese man-of-war
turns out people are not as into
invertebrate zoology as I am so it
doesn't really work but yeah so great
book opened advice about what holds
people back from contributing to open
source can't break code I'm not really
good at this I just be a burden there
they have people who are smarter than me
I've never thought any of these things
I'm kidding my first big contribution
was in art for data science for those of
you can't see there was almost four R's
in one of the mentions of her as a
result my dog's name ended up in the
acknowledgement section of our for data
science what I was talking about this
yesterday
nobody wants a typo in their book and or
package and or code and/or life unless
the pun in which case keep it so again
like go for it fix typos another good
diagram that's not about data scientist
turns out that confusion and
contribution also overlap you don't have
to wait to be like done I'm not finished
product yet just ask my parents but that
doesn't mean that there's no way for me
to contribute in my own like weird
learning Yee excited way and you never
know when what you're doing is gonna be
helpful to someone else so yeah Hadley
mentioned this really cool package that
works with shiny called pool and
being helpful and a major contributor
like I am I responded with an archer
guess to the surprise of no one but
turned out that yeah if it weren't for
that gift Matt Dickinson never would
have found the package he needed so
who's laughing now phrasing boom
inappropriate yes so thank you in
addition to Pam and Katya to all these
people who let me like mess with their
packages and then like hired me they may
be regretting that now but and thanks
Jared for having me um all these like
real data scientists up here have been
really great and yeah so that's my jam
and danger zone oh yeah whoever that was
you two
[Applause]